[Applaudissements]
alors c'est à dire cette appli périscope
du coup j'ai essayé moi aussi cette
aprem dans les loges
wesh des gros tranquillement en loge
avec montceau ce ballet y côtoie qu ils
menti à enora amédée coup de pression
loges
non mais tous avaient des coups de
pression tu as vu la gueule c'est pas
toi bien mais et moyens de vie c'est
chaud
un vase y en a il dit valérie benaïm
meilleur chronicles 2 tpp est cassée
quitter gars sûrement lisa tu vois là
mais voilà ils incluent une baisse de la
demande est plutôt jean-michel berruti
timo ravasi gens me titille guez
homblières s'échauffent et à dubaï dit
quoi brenda cette [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
vous n'étiez pas être motivée conversion
je suis pas louper le retour de koh
lanta ge com ouvre devant ma télé les
aventuriers sont magnifiques cette année
déjà en est le gars qui t'expliquent le
plan qu'il a mis en place pour sortir un
autre gars mais au bout d'un jour